now we have some breaking news for you
here on Sky News and Chris Hipkins is
set to become New Zealand's next prime
minister he's now the only candidate to
enter the race to replace Jacinda Arden
who of course uh bravely stepped down
saying that she had nothing left in the
tank and thought it best to step down
after a busy few years as prime minister
now Chris Hipkins is 44 years old he
does still need to get an endorsement on
Sunday from his labor party colleagues
in Parliament but that seems now to just
be a formality since he is now the only
candidate in the race to replace Jacinda
Arden told you a bit about him he rose
to fame and became a household name of
thoughts during the covid-19 pandemic
when he was appointed Minister for
covid-19 in November 2020 and was hailed
around the world for leaving the country
virus free for the first half of 2021
but of course criticism grew over the
harsh lockdown uh rules
um when of course covert Delta broke so
Chris Hipkins former covid-19 Minister
for New Zealand set to be New Zealand's
next prime minister and replaced Jacinda
Arden since he is now the only candidate
in the running but still needs an
endorsement on Sunday from his labor
party colleagues